oh
you okay man? help CJ hey, my friend is choking
Ronnie : oh no, not CJ, not CJ, no
CJ : are you okay?
CJ : oh God, are you okay?
CJ : you're gonna be just fine
ronnie (pointing)
Thank you
CJ : Ronnie are you okay?
Ronnie : Oh? Yeah?
CJ : Are you sure?
Yeah yeah, don't touch don't touch. I'm so good
you did good good good. Good work good job. Thank you. You can go
CJ : okay, drink some water
Ronnie : Thank you so much. Yes, okay?
Ronnie : how is it look?
how is what look?
Ronnie : down there
it's not look good at all. Yeah was it look like? it's like your dick is trap in some slash of wood.
Ronnie : okay, i just.. i just.. i
Ronnie : i can't reach it, i just need you to go get down there and just pop it out
no, no i can't do that at all
Ronnie : C'mon, just.. you grab it and push it out
CJ : okay hi
CJ : I'm gonna help you, we're going to deflate the situation together okay?
Ronnie :Okay
CJ : Focus, Think about things that.. that turn you off. maybe like uhm..
Like your Grandma's underwear
Mm-Hmm, not working
CJ : Okay cool, uhm maybe like..
Buress : Ostridges
Ronnie : hey still stuck, still stuck
CJ : mitch hey, need ya' !
Ronnie; No no no, not mitch, don't bring mitch over
Ronnie : Hey Mitchell mitches here
Mitch : Ronnie, you pumped about the qualifiers buddy.
Ronnie : you know it man, I'm just I'm really really excited to quit my double major in robotics and computer scienc
And really really do something with my life. You don't need to look down there. Do not touch it right now
CJ : not even touching it, okay
Mitch : Wow, okay? so you got your beef and your biscuit stuck down there
It's gonna be okay. I've been through it too. Not a big deal
Ronnie : really?
Mitch : Yeah, absolutely I was stuck in a woman for hours once, couldn't get out
here summers biggest comedy arrived
You just ah uhm look at my boobs. you are staring
Summer : Whoa guys does anybody see this? he won't stop staring at my boobs.
Matt : I'm not
Mitch : Welcome to Baywatch
Mitch : That's how we roll
Baywatch
you